Kelly Owens first started experiencing
chronic pain when she was a child it
started when she Twisted her ankle when
she was 13 years old at a play rehearsal
then all of a sudden the other ankle
swelled up for no particular reason and
she developed debilitating
gastrointestinal issues eventually she
developed arthritis that spread to every
single joint in her body by the time she
was 26 she had been taking so much
medication including steroids to try to
control what was happening in her body
with this immune response that she
developed osteoporosis at 26. after this
sort of Dark Night of the Soul she
traveled to Amsterdam and spent six
months there getting this vagus nerve
implant that stimulates the nerve she
actually achieved full remission from
her symptoms she's been living a normal
life but when Kelly wrote about her
recovery online the response wasn't what
you might expect she was attacked
especially by people who continue to
struggle with chronic illnesses
you're treated as though you're on a
crusade to stop disabled people from
existing journalist Kat Rosenfield wrote
about Owen's story in a new article for
a reason titled is online illness
culture keeping people sick
if your identity is founded on being
sick it really precludes the possibility
of getting well disease can be socially
contagious the dancing plagues of the
17th century are replaced in our current
year for instance by a tourette-like
tick found on Tick Tock in which suffers
yell the word beans Rosenfield writes
beans
beans oh no thanks
and when it comes to Innovative
treatments for chronic illness the
entrenched identarianism within patient
communities is an obstacle for letting
people try things or at least to getting
them to a place where they want to try
in other words learning to live with
their symptoms becomes a trap the
problem is that accepting those
limitations and then framing them as a
sort of a heroic battle against not
disease but against an oppressive
society that won't accommodate you can
really entrench people into this
identity into this mindset that they're
defined by their limitations they're
defined by how unwell they are one of
the problems with that is that in the
quest to become a sort of a Warrior
against the oppressive ableist Society
that's keeping you down other things go
by the wayside including just like the
basic hope to get better to find a cure
you know to be well again if you want to
be healthy you must hate your disability
you hate this thing that makes you who
you are to get treatment if you see
illness as an identity it can become
like a form of conversion therapy a
person who orients their identity around
an illness is sometimes referred to as a
spooning which comes from a 2003 blog
post by Christine miserandino
she used spoons as a metaphor to kind of
describe the finite supply of energy
that she has as a chronically ill person
and so they have to make strategic
decisions day to day and hour to hour
about how they expend energy lest they
end up at the end of the day having
spent all of their spoons and they're
exhausted and they can't do anything
spoonies have illnesses ranging from
Crohn's to lupus to chronic lyme disease
and now long coven understandably
spoonies are seeking a community people
who believe them it's important to note
that Sweeney's are not attention Seekers
they're not making it up it's not all in
their heads these are people who are
genuinely sick genuinely suffering often
they've been suffering for years doctors
treat them very skeptically especially
if they have a disorder that has no
obvious organic cause it's just symptoms
so this battle to be believed about
what's happening in your body can of
course send people online in search of
anybody who does believe them
social media is primarily focused on
awareness raising when it comes to
individual spoony influencers but also
when it comes to Patient foundations
they're sort of public-facing persona is
not so focused on things like pursuing
Innovative therapies or pushing for a
cure because what plays well on social
media oftentimes is misery what goes
viral is is the unhappy patient who's
struggling it's just not as sexy and it
doesn't get as much traction to put this
other stuff out there
everybody in these communities I think
would desperately love to get better but
to have one of these chronic illnesses
is to suffer such a terrible cycle of
getting your hopes up and then being
disappointed they're constantly cycling
through different treatments they're
constantly looking for something that
works and it's really easy after going
through that for months for years you
know for 10 years to become really
downtrodden at some point people do just
give up hope because it's too painful to
keep getting their hopes up and then
having their hopes dashed
Kelly is a sort of a fascinating
dissident voice within the chronic
illness Community when you're so focused
on awareness raising as your main ethos
making people who have the disease
visible rather than making them better
you end up with an economy built around
the idea of people being sick and
staying sick and not getting better